are you gay oh my god place on fight I
just hope the dog likes the bath because
I don't want it to be scared I have
given a cat a bath before and it was an
awful experience so I'm kind of just
hoping this is a little bit better than
that it's three of us against one so I
think we can do this yeah hi he's really
nice I'm just like not really sure how
to handle dogs I guess we're gonna give
a dog a bath now
[Music]
she's so slippery all right get that
little coupe just have over it
Oh perfect yeah you can just pick that
way Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh daddy we started to like you all
right here we go ah again maybe my loves
were not the best idea it wasn't as bad
as I thought it was going to be he was
really chill Spencer here is a really
good boy and I'm very happy I got to
give you a bath out of all the dogs in
the world
I actually really connected with this
dog I'm smelling him now and I feel like
we didn't do that kid a [ __ ] ha ha but
that might just be the wet dogs what
though
I just don't really know
[Music]